Let's go to.
Oh, let's go to Don Tel. in Florida.
Don, tell in Florida what's going on.
Don tell.
Hey, David.
First forgot to say that you've been doing.
I appreciate that you've been doing what you
can to like provided no one to take to all
the protest of what's going on right now.
Thank you.
And so I have to talk about this this protest
that I want to talk about.
The first is the stunning display of gratuitous
violence and lawlessness of school police
officers in police departments across the
country.
Ironically, people are protesting police brutality.
Right.
And in fact, is even worse than that.
Don, tell and don't tell.
Please do me the favor of keeping the phone
just a little further from your mouth that
the mouthpiece, because you're coming in hot
and we can't control it on our end too well
right now.
It's not it's actually there's an even crazier
hypocrisy, which is all of this is was catalyzed
by police brutality.
And the president came out and said, I think
the governors need to be more brutal in their
responses, which could not be more backward.
So, yes, I agree with you.
Spot on with with the first part.
Go ahead.
And so these are people who lost their job.
They are trying to maintain the peace.
Yes.
And what we're seeing is they're doing the
exact opposite.
They're the ones who are initiating the violence.
The overwhelming majority of time at these
peaceful protests.
So and a lot of the time when we see these
videos, normally when we see videos of police
brutality, a lot of people in this country
on the left and on the right, they say that
those are just the bad apples.
The overwhelming majority of the police, they're
good, they're law abiding and all of that.
Yeah.
But all of that went up in smoke over the
last few days when the entire police departments,
that police precinct mobilized to violently
break up lawful protest.
And the good police officers are law abiding
police officers.
They didn't intervene and they didn't do anything.
Wow.
The other police officers were assaulting
protesters, which is illegal.
And they could be arrested for, by the way.
Yeah.
And in fact, you think about.
Yeah, go ahead.
Yes.
What do you think about the idea of the police
officers who have been on video assaulting
protesters and unlawfully breaking a constitutionally
protected protest?
When you think about them being arrested and
prosecuted.
Yeah.
So I hope that they are.
I mean, I hope every internal affairs.
And this is I'm going to have a segment actually
coming up later on the show today where I'm
going to talk about exactly how police training
should be totally restructured.
But we I hope that these videos that are spreading
like wildfire are actually turned over.
And look that by police internal investigation
departments.
My understanding is that there have been some
officers caught on tape who already are now
entering the discipline process.
You know, we'll have to follow to see if anything
actually comes of it.
But I'm completely with you.
And in fact, I tweeted a couple of days ago.
Are are we building a list of names or are
we identifying the people that are so brutally
going, you know, going after even press, like
people who are just there reporting on what's
going on?
They should.
All we've got we've got to be taking names
and and going after all of the ones that have
broken the law.
And so that's a tough one to talk about, is
the looting.
So, yes, there are people who are opportunistic
and they aren't really involved in the George
Floyd protest.
Right.
And they see this as an opportunity to take
advantage of the situation.
Yes, that's true.
But if there are also people who are involved
in the protest who are engaged in looting,
too.
So the word out for me, it all goes back to
the question of would people be rioting?
Will people be looting if they were financially
financially secure?
Because people are forgetting we are in the
middle of an economic depression.
Forty million people have lost their jobs.
Forty percent of small businesses might be
permanently close in the next couple months.
Right, Joe?
Thousands of landlords right now are in court
filing a bitch for eviction.
So that as soon as these temporary bans are
lifted in the next couple of days, they can
start drawing people out on the street.
So this is the response from our government,
Democrats and Republicans has been to ignore
the economic depression and leave people high
and dry by the bail out corporations and the
richest people in the country to the tune
of trillions of dollars.
And before all of this even happened, we were
already dealing with historic wealth inequality
in this country.
And the living the economic case for a lot
of people were desperate.
So when you out this on top, of course, you're
going to get booted.
So my suggestion to people, if you want to
stop the looting, if you want to limit the
looting, is not to show the people who are
out there doing it.
It's not even sure.
You're not going to do it by calling them
out.
If you want them to stop moving, the way I
see it, the best way to do it is to have them
organize and and do targeted protest at the
politicians that Congress.
Cool.
I've got that done.
I think I get the point.
Don't tell.
You're coming.
You're coming in so distorted that I'm going
to have to let you go.
But I basically agree with you.
However, I wouldn't absolve any individual
looter of the fact that they are breaking
the law.
But you're completely right that we can't
ignore the circumstances that lead to people
feeling like they need to loot.
There's no question about it.
I'm with you, Don.
Tell on that.
OK.
And I'll let you go.
And we we thought our phone system was working
perfectly and then Don tell was just coming
in so hot.
Going to have to keep looking into that.